kinder sind dumm also nicht jedes kind
ist summen aber ich war schon ziemlich
dumm und kinder geht noch oft in
irgendwelchen schulthess klassenarbeiten
et cetera komische antworten und wir
schauen uns heute mal ein paar lustige
schüler an bord die mir ausgesucht hat
ist die hier
du hast 10 kekse jemand fragte ich nach
zwei keksen wie viele kekse hast du noch
zehn war die antwort von dem mann
scheint etwas dickeren kind würde diese
pyramide mit den grundbedürfnissen nach
marxloh ich habe mir da kubik und
sozialwissenschaften und was alles immer
ganz cool gefunden
deswegen die grundbedürfnisse nach maß
für sollten eigentlich jedem mehr oder
weniger bekannt sein
also ganz unten so die verpflegung dass
man isst und trinkt und dann weiter nach
oben halt zur selbstverwirklichung glück
etc das kind von dieser aufgabe hat
allerdings geschrieben finster süßlich
keine pommes und schnitzel also das
wichtigste in seinem leben ums überleben
ist pizza ganz unten hier sollte die
person das richtige antwort finden für
die kurzfassung als beispielsweise bei
km h kilometer pro stunde bei
transformator oder beispielsweise
überall hat er allgemein geschrieben
aber beim zdf der geschrieben zentrum
der finsternis
wie kommt man denn auch so war die
nächste schüler antwort ist finde ich
nicht dumm oder lustig oder irgendwie so
aber einfach voll süßer ich habe genau
vorstellen was das für schüler war die
frage war auf jeden fall schreiber auf
wie du nach dem prädikat fragst und der
schüler namens adrian hat geantwortet
darf ich bitte den prädikat haben
so richtig lieber noch so heftig bitte
das prädikat das hilft es wieder so
komplett bescheuert und zwar weil die
aufgabe diesmal auf englisch neue
batterie
also man soll die formen benennen die
beispielsweise wenn da ein quadrat ist
dann schreibt quadrat runter
der schüler hat den formen allerdings
namen gegeben wie beispielsweise
pattinson cage oder harry ich hätte dir
einfach aufgrund eines vom russen
einsplus gepfiffen
die nächste schüler antwort finde ich
übel amüsant und zwar winter und gefragt
wie heißt das virus das für aids
verantwortlich ist und die richtige
antwort war natürlich hiv der schüler
allerdings geschrieben hsv da holt sich
aber ein bisschen recht geben also ich
bin ja fußball fan vom ersten fc köln
hier weil ich in köln wohne und die
prügeln sich gerade die ganze zeit mit
dem hsv um den ersten platz in der
zweiten liga deswegen habe ich auf jeden
fall hart schmunzeln wissen dass jetzt
die nächste schülerhand einfach bäume
die blätter haben nennt man raum wollen
wir die nadeln haben wenn man will ja
entscheiden konnten wir mit blättern
steht nennt man wald weil der die
nadelbäume vorkommen nennt man halt
wälder ende
das ist es jetzt richtig aber das ist
genauso wie man sagt wann starb mozart
ja vor ein paar jahren das sind
eigentlich alles antworten für die man
trotzdem als lehrer teil punkte vergeben
müsste weil es ist ja richtig die
nächste schüler antwort ist einfach
komplett komplett facebook einfach
schreiben sie weiter
der schüler schreibt halt weiter dass
schulkinder teilweise für gedanken haben
[Applaus]
wir finden so antworten sonst kindern
die jetzt wahrscheinlich komödien sind
das ist auch so eine standard schüler an
heute glaube ich jeder einfach kennt da
steht einfach finde ich einfach ins
eigene kleidung sagen ja hier ist der
nächsten schüler antwort denke ich mir
halt ok das könnte auch safestick sein
weil eigentlich jeder schüler der
irgendwie den ansporn hat was zu
erreichen in der schule
der hätte sowas nicht geschrieben
angenommen einlass kurven kostet 1 euro
79 du hast fünf euro bei dir wie viele
gläser kurven kaufst du damit der
rechenweg existiert einfach nicht ja
keines ich gehe zum chips regal und
kaufen wir zwei tüten erdnussflips würde
ich auch so machen welche
voraussetzungen muss eine frau erfüllen
um schwanger werden zu können und die
antwort war so richtig süßes kann ich
mir richtig vorstellen wie das soll
kleines junges mädchen irgendwie ja wie
die das schreiben geschrieben hat bevor
sie schwanger werden darf muss sie einen
schwangerschaftstest bestehen als wenn
das wieder für
prüfung ist auch so was kommen wirklich
nur kinder die antwort eines spielers
die ich euch jetzt zeige dann wirklich
so bisherigen die lustigste schüler
antwort die ich je gelesen habe wurde
die unabhängigkeitserklärung
unterzeichnet ganz unten
hier sollte der schüler beziehungsweise
die schülerinnen eine tierart angeben
die sich nicht aus eigener kraft
fortbewegen kann
tote tiere ich meine es ist nicht falsch
ich denke mir halten lehrer müssten viel
viel viel viel mehr teil punkte vergeben
für sowas einfach oder wird wie seht ihr
das das erste bild wird sich zeigen
ist ein test des sag ich mal grund auf
einer explosion in einer münchner schule
zu einigen münchner denkmälern und die
erste frage war was hast du über den tag
des offenen denkmals gelernt was du bist
jetzt noch nicht wusstest die antwort
von dem schüler war ich wusste nicht
dass er am 8 september ist ja das war
auf jeden fall ein kleiner ausflug wenn
er das einzige anlass sich der schüler
erinnern kann doch ist an welchem tag
die tat waren in welcher situation
könnte diese informationen hilfreich
sein vielleicht bei wer wird millionär
genau welche denkmäler haben wir
zusammen besucht alle verstehe ich aber
immer wenn wir irgendwelche explosion
gemacht haben kann auch sofort hätten
wir uns den ganzen tag alles mögliche
was langweilig ist angeschaut die
nächste schüler antwort ist auch wieder
komplett bescheuert und ich glaube sogar
steak und zwar die frage was war der
größten errungenschaften der alten römer
sie kommen um latein kein kind in der
grundschule weiß latein alte römer die
nächste schüler antwort es wieder so
richtig süß und zwar diese fee beschützt
frage eins davon als falsch bewertet zu
werden der hat wohl irgendein schüler
oder eine schülerin die erste frage
falsch beantwortet und hat dann einfach
so eine feder hin gemalt von wegen hey
lehrerin bitte bewerten sie die frage
nicht als falsch ich mein bewerten sie
die antwort nicht als falsch das habe
ich aber tatsächlich auch mal gemacht
und zwar war das in irgendeiner klausur
sogar auf einem gymnasium schon
mittlerweile gewesen dann dass ich eine
frage
also ich konnte alles beantworten außer
eine frage da das wissen nur drei punkte
dann schreibe ich halt etwas lustiges
hin hab ich halt irgendwie so ein text
den geschrieben von wegen hallo herr
lehrer ich habe wirklich überhaupt
keinen plan was da ist die antwort ist
ich glaube ich war in der stunde nicht
da oder krank ich kann ihn einfach nur
das und das dazu sagen ich habe sogar
einen punkt bekommen weil ich ihnen
dafür noch was anderes sagen konnte was
zwar nichts mit der frage zu tun hatte
aber keine ahnung also ich glaube ein
großer tipp den man blickte schülern
leben kann also vielen von euch ja
wahrscheinlich auch es immer etwas hin
schreiben wir eine aufgabe auch wenn ihr
nichts wisst schreibt trotzdem
irgendeinen rechenweg in irgendwas was
in eurem kopf ist so weniger als 0
punkte könnt ihr nicht bekommen in
dieser schüler einer fünften klasse ist
die aufgabe gewesen löse folgende
gleichungen und beeindrucken mich schon
den gleichungen wurde keine gelöst
stattdessen wurde untendrunter
geschrieben von dem schüler als lösung
es ist nicht meine motivation anderen
menschen zu imponieren
das was die schlagfertige antwort kommen
wir nun allerdings schon zu letzten
schüler antwort die ich hier heute
rausgesucht habe freunde und zwar
beginnt das ganze relativ gut und zwar
die erste frage ist wie viele stunden
hat einen tag und natürlich steigt die
person 24 in die zweite also die nächste
frage die dann kam war wie viele minuten
hat eine stunde und die haben natürlich
auch 60 geantwortet daher als drittes
kamen wie viele tage hat ein jahr und
dann mit 365 geantwortet und die vierte
frage war ist die zahl als sechs eine
gerade oder eine ungerade zahl und die
person hat gerade geantwortet
bisher wird hier wirklich alles richtig
beantwortet doch dann kam die fünfte
frage und die lautet woher weißt du ob
sie gerade oder ungerade ist weil ich
ziemlich clever bin ich richtig
es ist eigentlich eine richtige antwort
ich glaube der leser heute eigentlich so
eine antwort haben wie weil es durch die
zahl zwei teilbar ist aber dass zu
clever liszt wird ich zumindest auch
mitteilungen durchgelassen arbeitsstätte
durch das heutige bietet allerdings auch
beenden meine damen und herren wenn es
euch meine reaktion auf einige
besteuerte antworten von schülern in
klassenarbeiten gefallen haben dann
lasst mal einen like das soll ich das
ganze noch mal hoch laden
also es gibt ja unzählige dumme
antworten von schülern in
klassenarbeiten schreibt ihr geld und in
die kommentare freunde geschickt unter
dem video auch abonieren wenn ihr noch
kein teil der luxus sein und auch keine
videos mehr verpassen wollt und wenn ich
schon abonnent seit steht gern auf die
glocke denn dann bekommen die
automatisch auf ihr handy eine
benachrichtigung wenn ich ein neues
video hochladen und dann seid ihr
vielleicht irgendwann mal der erste der
einen kommentar schreiben immer in zwei
fällen gibt es seit gestern im blut
shopping.de zu kaufen der jetzt teil der
neuen kollektion die gestern drauf haben
aber nun durch das video an der stelle
ist erst mal beenden
[Musik]